[Musique]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur et
[Musique]
me semble être formidable raison d'être
à ces défis
[Musique]
messieurs bonjour use interview
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne youtube qui
s'appelle signe que review on aurait
aimé avoir votre avis sur les derniers
le yak dernières gesticulations de nos
gouvernants concernant la surveillance
on va commencer avec jérémie zimmermann
jérémie zimmerman bonjour qu'est ce que
vous pouvez lui dire qu'est ce que je
peux dire beaucoup de choses on est dans
une période un petit peu trouble espèce
de d'accélération de la spirale
sécuritaire qui ont envie de pulls en
septembre 2001 un empilement mesure
législative d'une espèce de millefeuille
politique législatif qui nous qui nous
pousse toujours plus loin dans la
surveillance de masse et dans ce qui
ressemble de plus en plus c'est une
sorte de dérive autoritaire des
gouvernements occidentaux
une forme de réponse à la terreur par la
terreur qui en quelque sorte fait le jeu
des terroristes
on l'a vu en france au cours de ces
douze derniers mois il ya eu vote de la
loi de programmation militaire lpm qui
autorise une surveillance de masse par
des entités administratives pour des
types de données et des sources
particulièrement floues dans la loi et
pour des types de crimes pour des types
d' enquête là aussi particulièrement
vaste on a suivi de très près de la loi
antiterroriste voté en novembre 2014 qui
outre restriction de liberté de
mouvement instaure cette nouvelle
catégorie de citoyens qui sont des
suspects et futurs terroristes pour
lesquelles la police à peu près tous les
droits de le restreindre leur liberté de
mouvement de les surveiller
et c est là qu elle loi
anti terreau à toute cette cette notion
enfin sort je crois du droit de la
presse cette notion d' apologie du
terrorisme pour en faire un délit et
donne aux pouvoirs publics à l'exécutif
donc au ministère de l'intérieur
la possibilité de censurer des sites
internet qui ferait l'apologie du
terrorisme alors le 8 janvier au
lendemain du massacre de charlie hebdo
le gouvernement français envoyait à
bruxelles son projet de décret
d'application de la loppsi et de la loi
terreau concernant le la censure c'était
dur et chauffé
donc bon la loppsi ça fait des années
qu'elle avait été votée en 2010 je crois
le gouvernement à l'époque était celui
de françois fillon et les députés
socialistes étaient vent debout contre
la censure ont déposé un recours au
conseil constitutionnel
très fournie qui avait été rejeté mais
était complètement opposés à cette
censure qu'ils ont voté dès demain
lorsqu'il s'agissait de l'apologie du
terrorisme dont il s'agissait du même
décret ça c'est intéressant
un même décret pour une loi votée sous
sarkozy et pour une loi votée sous
rowland qui disait exactement la même
chose et qui est transmise à bruxelles
le lendemain des attaques
le décret a été depuis publié et on
attend les détails d'implémentation
est ce que l'on a donc depuis depuis
deux jours depuis la publication de ce
décret c'est aujourd'hui en france une
censure administrative d'internet pour
les sites pédopornographiques pour les
sites faisant l'apologie du terrorisme
c'est évident que cette liste de motifs
va s'élargir au cours du temps on attend
de voir les charlots du disque et du
film obtenir eux aussi que le ministère
de machin demande à ce qu'on enlève des
sites de l'internet
on attend de voir ce qui va se passer on
l'a vu avec les récentes arrestations et
mises en examen pour apologie du
terrorisme que quand un ado republie une
caricature qui reprend une caricature de
charlie hebdo qui disait
le coran c'est de la merde ça n'arrête
pas les balles pour dire charlie c'est
de la merde ça n'arrête pas de les
balles dans une mise en abyme assez à
ses splendides ce qui pourrait être
considéré comme de l'humour peut-être
pas forcément drôle par certains que
boom s'est qualifié d' apologie du
terrorisme
le truc de dieudonné qui a obtenu sa
campagne de pub internationale en disant
je me sens charlie coulibaly apologie du
terrorisme etc
si c'est ce même type de propos qui sont
considérés comme apologie du terrorisme
par le ministère de l'intérieur qui va
automatiquement envoyé un message aux
fournisseurs d'accès pour leur demander
de d'empêcher d'accéder à ces recettes
une privatisation de la justice
là c'est une administrative à sion une
executive isation ses rangs un
contournement la justice ça c'est sûr
c'est plus de la justice ancêtres ce
sens qui a pas de juge est ce que ces
derniers en date est ce que c'est un
ersatz de la stasi c'est-à-dire un
renforcement de la police administrative
à un tel point qu'on est capable de bail
passé le juge écoute j'ai du mal avec
les analogies historiques comme ça pour
dire est-ce que c'est pire ou mieux que
la stasi plus gentil ou plus méchant que
les nazis pire parce que ça sent est-ce
que ça sent comme une chose est sûre
c'est que c'est un renforcement des
pouvoirs de l'exécutif aux dépens du
judiciaire qui dans une démocratie et le
gardien des libertés fondamentales que
c'est une dérive sécuritaire et surtout
c'est quelque chose qui me dérange au
plus haut point dans ma ce qui me reste
de fibre républicaine si j'ose dire
c'est que c'est une tendance qui touche
exactement la même façon la droite et la
gauche eu une heure et demie après les
massacres de charlie hebdo il y avait un
communiqué de l'ump pour dire que l'ump
soutiendraient le gouvernement dans tout
ce qu'ils feraient en matière de
sécurité
et lorsque la loi terro a été votée on a
vu les gens à la droite de
à droite pose une question à temps il y
avait une série mariani et jacques myard
qui applaudissait le gouvernement pour
samoa terroristes donc quand on en voit
d'autres de l'autre côté qui sont en
train d'encaisser des points en dix ans
ump est tous les mêmes et qu'on voit un
mp et ps voté les mêmes elles mêmes
saleté est quelque chose qui fait très
bien qu'on prend plus le temps de
réfléchir
mais c'est normal il ya une telle
émotion face à charlie hebdo que
forcément les politiques se sentent
obligés de faire quelque chose de
communiquer leurs actions et ses 2 c'est
une vieille méthode qui avait qui a
connu son heure de gloire du temps de
sarkozy c'est un fait divers une loi est
bien là ça continue dans le même sens il
ya le fait divers
charlie hebdo il faut montrer qu'on est
aux commandes il faut montrer qu'on fait
quelque chose et si tu veux c'est une
façon de montrer comme un début de
présentation tristan nitot eksmo dit
l'un
vous avez fait une thèse sur la
surveillance vous êtes en train de faire
des gestes j'écris j'écris un livre sur
sur la surveillance tout à fait parce
que c'est
c'est un sujet qui me préoccupe
énormément aujourd'hui pas simplement
dans le cadre qu'on discute aujourd'hui
mais ça fait des années que ça commence
avec tout ce qui est business model
autour du profilage des internautes et
c'est donc plus largement on voit la
confluence des intérêts économiques et
la surveillance par par les états et les
services secrets travailler ensemble par
exemple les révélations snowden ont été
très très intéressante de ce point de
vue là et et la rebelle voilà je viens
de quitter mon job j'ai du temps pour
les faire un livre et je me précipite je
prends ce temps pour écrire ce livre
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à
expliquer pour faire comprendre aux gens
que la surveillance ces quelques soient
les risques - quels sont les risques si
comme vous appelez la plèbe les gens ne
comprennent pas la problématique
quels sont les risques en bas il ya il y
avait des tas de risques là premièrement
le fait que quand on est quand on se
sait surveillé en permanence en fait on
s'autocensure et on qu'on s'habitue à ça
et ça pousse à la conformité et
s'étendent à une standardisation des
attitudes des gens et ce depuis qu'ils
sont tout petits et pourtant on a besoin
de cet espace de liberté de vie privée
c'est un grand classique
si si quelqu'un chante sous la douche
moi je sais quand je chante sous la
douche je chante pas toujours très bien
et puis je m'améliore au fil du temps
mais s'il ya quelqu'un à côté et
j'entends une porte qui s'ouvre et je
sais que je suis entendu sous la douche
en train de mal chanté sa coupe tout
parce que et ça veut parce que j'ose pas
exprimé ses difficultés cet
apprentissage est donc je me tais et si
on se sent surveillé en permanence on va
pas osé est ridicule on va pas osé
essayer de nouvelles choses venir on va
pas osé être journaliste on va poser de
juger aurait pas osé plaint d'être parce
que qu'est-ce que pour pour ajouter
quelque chose ici sur ce que tu dis
tristan c'est très juste et ce dont on
parle ici ça fait déjà fait des années
qu'on
de ces sujets là évidemment depuis
depuis snowden là on a on a un boulevard
pour s'exprimer sur ces questions et
plus en plus de gens réalisent
l'importance de ça mais j'ai un vrai
problème quand on parle de protection de
la vie privée à une liberté fondamentale
voyez-vous france pays des droits de
l'homme tout si tout ça et beaucoup de
gens s'en cogne et se disent vas mois
tant que j'ai pas mangé
tant que je galère pour payer mon loyer
qu'est ce que j'irais moment non merde
et à défendre les libertés fondamentales
en réalité ce que tu décris ici quelque
chose de beaucoup plus personnel on
parle pas de projection de vie privée on
parle d'intimité et l'intimité tout le
monde en a une et tout le monde comprend
ça l'intimité c'est ces moments dans
lesquels on est tout nu au propre et au
figuré dans lesquels on est on est
vraiment soi même sans costume sans
masquer son rôle à jouer
on est en pleine confiance soit seul
soit avec les gens avec qui on choisit
de l'être et c'est dans ces espaces que
comme tu dis on n'est pas jugé par ses
pairs et donc c'est ça c'est pas
protéger une liberté fondamentale
c'est aussi ça mais avons tous et
protéger nos intimités notre droit à
l'intimité
vu que c'est dans ces moments d'intimité
que l'on va pouvoir comme tu dis avec
l'exemple de la douche qu'on va pouvoir
expérimenter avec de nouvelles zones et
de nouvelles phases ont chanté avec
nouvelles idées de nouvelles opinion
mais expérimenté implique de se tromper
implique de ne pas se sentir jugé par
ses pairs et sans cette expérimentation
et bien voilà on ne peut pas développer
qu'il en est on ne peut pas développer
son identité donc c'est un combat pour
nom les intimités pour nos identités
je sais pour moi c'est essentiel qu'on
aime qu'on développe ça de cette façon
là on a on a korben de table salle
corbelle s'élève à lui quand ben quand
tu entends alors je te tutoie parce que
là teddy journalistes y ait un rayon la
collusion
bon je suis très fier quand même qu'en
30 ans à la quête toi en tant que père
de famille en tant qu'internaute qu'est
ce que ça te fais moi je suis sensible à
tout ça
mais pour moi ce qu'on disait par
rapport à la loi qui ont été votées la
après les attentats de charlie hebdo
pour moi tout ça c'est quelque chose qui
est en marche depuis longtemps et c'est
ce genre de faits divers comme des
tristes ans c'est juste la bonne occase
pour deux places et la plume quoi et
c'est juste parce que les enfin à mon
sens l'appareil politique qui a le
contrôle sur pas mal de choses sur les
médias sur ce qui se dit et c'est
internet c'est un outil qui est assez
libre n'importe quel gars voilà décide
d'ouvrir ainsi de faire une de mettre
une vidéo en ligne de s'exprimer pour
avoir le contrôle là dessus c'est plus
compliqué est passé par un juge c'est
long donc c'est vrai que le côté
on a la petite louane à la petite le
petit levier administratif et on peut
bloquer tout ce qu'on veut c'est quand
même très on va dire très pratique
puisque c'est un peu enfin pour moi
c'est qu'elle est c'est nice et surtout
très inefficace alors pour passer mais
efficace on l'a vue là je crois que
c'était hier le pirate bay points et ce
a été bloqué au niveau dns par une
autorité administrative donc certains
fournisseurs d'accès à bloquer le dns et
donc quand on essaye d'aller sur pirate
bay point est ce qu'on peut pas re avons
dramatique sauf qu'en fait ça ça ne fait
suer que les gens qui savent pas qu'on
peut utiliser un autre dns si lui n'est
pas bloqué donc en gros ça normal que
les gens qui n'iraient pas sur pirate
bay 7 47 suis quand même parce que ça
c'est une première méthode de blocage
mais ça peut monter assez vite crescendo
ces rpg toi tu vas contourner ils vont
remettre un autre russie on va
contourner et à un moment on va arriver
au dpi et on va arriver alors dpi deep
packet inspection cercle en gros le
fournisseur d'accès va regarder ce qui
passe dans les les petits paquets va va
tout éplucher et là pour bloquer on va
dire
à la surface nativement le truc et d
alerte est donnée l'alertent et même si
on passe par des réseaux on va dire
darknet genre torre ou
oui toupine ce genre de choses ça aussi
ça peut être on va dire alors je disais
au niveau de l'efficacité
déjà petite parenthèse petite parenthèse
purement sémantique le terme darknet je
pense a été inventé par nos ennemis pour
faire croire que ce qui est chiffré ou
anonymes sur internet c'est le mal
en gros eric schmidt pdg de google dit
oh bien sûr que vous pouvez être anonyme
sur internet
si vous la lettre anonyme sur internet
que vous avez un crime à commettre en
gros être anonyme sur internet c'est
être impossible pour google aspiré
donc ça veut dire ne pas générer de
profits pour google dont google c'est
l'ennemi ce qui est appelé par les
journalistes non éduqués darknet c'est
la capacité de deux ordinateurs a parlé
le protocole de leur choix qu'ils soient
chiffrées ou non chiffrée anonyme ou pas
et cette capacité de deux ordinateurs a
parlé le protocole de leur choix sans
intermédiaire sans garde barrière c'est
ce qu'on appelle internet internet
l'imaginaire si jérémy de rappeler ce
qu'on appelle darknet celle interne
c'est toute la partie d'internet qui
n'est pas accessible à google et dans
laquelle on peut s'exprimer librement
sans être traqués
c'est l'internet qu'on veut c'est
l'internet libre mais je fais avec et au
service des gens et quand même on en
vient à se reprendre ses termes
mais je dis ça semble sentent attaqués
moi parce que je connais des gens qui
sont qui sont enfin voilà qui ont une
réflexion sur le sujet d'où l'importance
du sens des mots et se battre pour le
moment la fin n'a pas envie de parler de
vous parler du sens globo
beaucoup de personnes ont vu jérémie
zimmermann de votre vidéo lors de votre
audition au sénat
as tu vois un bon je te tutoie vous voir
on a vu ta vidéo du sénat où tu as été
un peu véhément avec le pauvre un homme
politique c'est c'était très intéressant
sur la sémantique et sur la sémiologie
qu'elle est quelle est la réaction que
tu as face aux tournois des politiques
quant à leur perception des des
problématiques qu'est ce que ça te fait
en temps comme tu été amené à parler de
surveillance de problèmes de société
c'est censé être leur créneau et on voit
bien qu'on fasse soit ils ont un agenda
swahili projet de leur peur mais la
plupart du temps il n'y connaissait rien
du style est ce que moi ce que j'ai vu
c'est que les états assez hostile à ce
que jérémy ne dit jamais je suis partagé
parce que d'un côté
à titre personnel j'étais un petit peu
excédée parce que bon déjà parce que je
suis plus porte parole de la quadrature
du net m'a chanté ma parole un petit peu
plus libre et puis je fais un peu moins
disons que j'ai plus financé pour faire
à plein dans ce genre de ce genre de
claque et que j'arrive dans une salle
aux trois quarts vide avec en face de
moi
le sénateur jean pierre sueur qui
défendent elles à la la loi de
programmation militaire en expliquant
que bien sûr il ya des contrôles ya des
trucs et machins se noue cje pas si ces
faits intoxiqué par les services ou s'il
était tenu par tel ou tel secret où et
pourquoi tu essaies pas de le piéger
quand on est en face de quelqu'un comme
ça non quand je dis pas comment vous
faites pour envoyer un mail quel est
votre travail d'heure c'est pas le vin
je pense que c'est pas lieu donc j'étais
à titre personnel un petit peu un petit
peu sur les dents plus avec le contexte
politique actuel
voilà en face de chez moi j'ai des
militaires avec des famas chargé
aujourd'hui chargé en fait non je
voudrais dire qu'à ce niveau de
vigipirate ci mais peut-être y seront et
charlotte
j'ai entendu dire qu'on est au plus haut
niveau de vigipirate où ça veut dire que
les armes sont chargés par des fois mais
je vais peut-être mais c'est un secret
de polichinelle mais en fait il paraît
que non mais ce bon mais il faut pas
dire qu'ils sont préchargés pas sont
évidemment en fonction n'apporte
ce héros militaire qui se gèlent devant
des lieux sans pour cela projette ni
l'image d'une bonne gestion des finances
publiques ni de la sécurité de voir des
petits jeunes de 19 en train de se geler
les couilles des armes automatiques à la
main et je peux pas tirer en vide avec
un famas a donc enfin à moins de vouloir
tuer des passants donc est donc dans ce
contexte là j'étais disons un petit peu
un petit peu sur les dents et aimer le
le fond de ce qui m'a le plus
ce qui m'a le plus excédés c'est d'avoir
l'impression de répéter les mêmes choses
depuis 10 ans leur expliquer pourquoi la
censure ça marche pas pourquoi c'est
contre-productif pourquoi c'est une
spirale descendante dont on ne peut pas
remonter pourquoi ça conduit aux abus
c'est des argumentaires entend
quadrature on les a écrits pour la
première fois en 2008 quand on venait de
se fonder à chaque nouvelle loi
sécuritaire on a répété les mêmes choses
à chaque loi sécuritaire on s'est fait
balayer plus ou moins plus ou moins
rapidement les dernières j'ai raconté
c'était l'ump et le ps qui voter
ensemble les trucs en se lançant
s'applaudissant et l'impression que ça
n'est qu'une étape de plus comme ça a
été dit bon j'aime pas trop le fait de
qualifier les soirs de charlie hebdo et
de hyper cacher de faits divers
parce que c'est en fait quand même
exceptionnel c'est pas si divers que ça
mais effectivement le premier fait venu
il y aurait pas eu ça sera peut-être été
dans trois mois dans quatre mois ça
aurait peut-être été un bep couteau ici
une bombinette là bas à ce niveau-là ça
n'importe même pas c'est le premier truc
devenu qui sert à faire avancer un
agenda qui existent déjà comme après le
11 septembre 2001 trois semaines après
le patriot act été votée aux états unis
on n'écrit pas une loi comme le patriot
act en trois semaines et ça a été
documenté le patriot act était déjà
écrit avant et naomi klein théorie ça
très bien dans son bouquin la théorie du
choc la stratégie la stratégie du choc
en expliquant que c'est
l'instrumentalisation des peurs dans une
opinion publique qui se manipule qui
servent à faire avancer un agenda
politique qu'on n'arriverait pas à
rendre acceptable autrement donc c'est
ça qui m'a vraiment mis par terre et en
gardant à l'esprit cette citation équipe
pour expliquer pour illustrer cette
stratégie du choc et surtout le rapport
des politiques assez à cet agenda
sécuritaire c'est cameron interrogé sur
la dernière loi terreau en date en
angleterre pour dire je vote ça parce
que je ne veux pas être accusé lorsqu'il
y aura un attentat de ne pas avoir fait
ce que j'ai pu faire lorsque je pouvais
le faire une espèce de paris sur le
futur du passé du futur qui d'un point
de vue grammatical déjà du mal à
articuler et qui montre que les
politiques à force de réagir le nez
posés sur des chiffres de sondages non
gouvernement plus aux instruments mais
gouverne à une représentation fédéraux
sur des chiffres de l'émotion des
instruments qui sont ceux du pouvoir et
que du coup tout ça est ouvert à toutes
les manipulations et donc l'impression
d'aller au sénat pour pisser dans un
violon
parce qu'on sait très bien que quel que
soit et je ne doute pas pour le coup des
bonnes intentions de la rapporteure à la
sénatrice goulet mais que quelles que
soient les conclusions du rapport on va
avoir dans quelques semaines une
nouvelle loi sur le renseignement est
que cette loi sur le renseignement ça va
être forcément plus de surveillance plus
de pouvoirs à l'exécutif et à la police
- le judiciaire et qu'internet 20 je
trouverai une parenthèse alors on a des
contacts tant que moi dans l'entité raw
on ne citera pas d'aujourd'hui pour
l'avoir tant les avants adore pour les
avoir eus au téléphone a pas très
longtemps on va se mettre à leur place
il ya 20 % de turnover dans les services
de renseignements intérieurs il ya un
burn-out de certains va parler français
les gens sont fatigués les gens sont
fatigués pour certains on leur donne pas
de moyens ils sont obligé d'imprimer les
blogs des attentats dans des attentats
et des radicaux islamistes parce cuisant
aucune perry et aucun périphérique
sécurisés ils ont peur ils seront pas
ils sont pas renseignés je vais revenir
devant tristan est ce que dans son
rapport en ce tutoiement est ce que dans
ton dans son rapport dans ta tête tu
aimais des préconisations pour les
politiques ou pour la population
qu'elles sont quels sont tes
préconisations alors il ya il règne en
a4 plus une préalable premièrement il
faut se documenter faut essayer de
comprendre comment ça marche tout ça
plutôt que de se laisser faire comme en
bas c'est pour ça que j'ai écrit le
livre qui est vraiment fait pour rendre
abordable toute cette problématique
pourquoi il faut la vie privée
qu'est ce que c'est qu'internet qu'est
ce que c'est que le cloud un faucon
traitement le cloud ça veut dire qu'on
utilise l'ordinateur quelqu'un d'autre
c'est faux que le comprendre comme ça et
puis après il ya quatre pistes étudiées
la première c'est d'utiliser du logiciel
libre
ces terres du logiciel dont on peut voir
et comprendre le code source pour voir
ce qui fait ça c'est absolument
indispensable on ne sait nous faire
comprendre que c'est une idée de hippies
la vérité c'est que c'est ce qui fait
tourner le monde et ce qui est de droit
de l'hommiste les droits de l'homme
distance décevoir voilà
pour moi c'est essentiel si on veut
contrôler et avoir sa liberté
avec le numérique qui monte chaque jour
en puissance il faut utiliser des
logiciels libres premièrement
deuxièmement il va falloir utiliser du
chiffrement ce qu'on appelle aussi de la
crypto c'est à dire que les échanges
qu'on fait sur internet et autres il
faut utiliser du chiffrement
ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut que nous
informaticiens ont rendu le chiffrement
facile à utiliser une clé gilles froment
au-dehors clés de chiffrement américaine
serait bien naïf on va commencer
doucement déjà essayé d'expliquer ce que
c'est que le chiffrement et commencé à
s'en servir le plus possible pour éviter
les grandes oreilles pour éviter
l'espionnage économique et vous n'avez
pas l'impression qu'on en ayant ce type
de préconisations vous renforcez les
terroristes en phase ou non je vais
faire le troll
non il faut il faut se protéger toute
façon parce qu'il ya un gros problème
aujourd'hui c'est quand on voit dans les
révélations snowden donc le lanceur
d'alert edouard snowden qui est à
communiquer des documents de la msa à
des journalistes en juin 2013 ans quand
on fouille un petit peu ce qu'il ya dans
cet énorme documentation parlement des
millions de documents
on voit très bien que en fait les vrais
clients de la haine et ça ça va être le
ministère de l'agriculture américain
ça va être les ministères du commerce
c'est que les images c'est de
l'espionnage industriel voilà économique
et pas simplement de la lutte
antiterroriste ou aux antilles
pas même pas pas simplement c'est que
c'est un rapport de la new america
foundation et je crois qu'il ya un
rapport d'une commission consultative la
maison blanche car il va à peu près aux
mêmes conclusions
a new american foundation avait trouvé
que c'est dans moins de 1% des cas
d'attentât terroriste déjoué qui a eu
besoin de la surveillance de masse donc
ça n'a absolument aucun impact vous dire
qu'on était là on a fait le niveau des
prix et donc il en reste deux puisque la
troisième ça va être l'auto hébergement
c'est à dire faire tourner si on a des
besoins de de cloud sert de d'un serveur
il faut pas que ça tourne chez google
mais il faut se tourner et faire
fonctionner sur un ordinateur sur lequel
on a le contrôle donc ça va être
probablement de l'auto hébergement donc
avoir une boîte peut être que ce serait
à terme notre box internet où vous
pourrez stocker nos propres données
et puis quatrièmement quatrième piste ça
va être changé le business model des
services d'internet aujourd'hui parce
qu'aujourd'hui le le truc qui fait
tourner l'internet commercial c'est la
publicité ciblée et la publicité ciblée
ça consiste à savoir un maximum de
choses sur l'utilisateur pour ensuite
monétiser ce savoir se profile sur
l'utilisateur
le monétiser auprès d'annonceurs et là
on comprend en fait que les annonceurs
seller vraiment les clients de google de
twitter et de facebook
c'est eux qui payent qui passe la
commande il passe sa commande et nous en
fait on est le produit qui est vendu à
ses annonceurs rires il ya une très
belle illustration québec et dans mon
livre on voit deux qu'au fond qui sont
dans une porcherie et le premier qui dit
à l'autre
ah t'as vu c'est génial la nourriture
est gratuite ici et l'autre lui répond
et en plus on est logé gratuitement et
la légende de de cet illustrateur deux
cochons discutant du modèle gratuit
parce que les voilà les deux couches les
cochons c'est nous on va finir débité en
saucisses et parce que nous on est on
est le produit qui est vendu aux vrais
clients qui sont les annonceurs et leurs
fois qu'on aura résolu ce problème de
business model et qu on aura compris que
si on veut un service de qualité au
service de l'utilisateur
il faut payer pas forcément beaucoup et
bien là on va réussir à avoir le
contrôle sur l'internet
korben alors on est des côtelettes
est-ce que tu as que tu as l'impression
qu'on est des côtelettes ouais
totalement enfin tu vois comment dans ta
vie de tous les jours
moi je vois autour de moi tout le monde
du 6 gmail rien que ça déjà
si les gens se passer dit mais ce serait
déjà beau pourquoi es tu toi tu utilises
plus j'aimais alors tu utilises quoi la
place moi je suis passé
moi je suis pas passé en auto est
largement au niveau des mails mais je
suis passé chez ovh
donc tu paye donc tu paye donc je le
paye c'est ben voilà
mais effectivement ça a pris aussi sein
de toute façon la vie pris fin et même
sait très bien que tu peux rien je pense
que tu as compris que la vie privée
justement
enfin de tout le sujet dont on parle il
ya un investissement que ce soit
financier ou que ça soit en termes de
connaissances et d'implication aux
techniques pour s'y mettre et monte son
petit rue chez soi il faut qu'on y'a les
présents si on reste comme des veaux
voilà un peu comme les gens qui
regardent la télé qui font que regarder
la télé s'ils vont pas se documenter eux
mêmes sur le net ils vont pas essayer de
rencontrer des gens et c'est leur seule
fenêtre vers le monde c'est la télé
c'est une chose avec
avec ce qu'on fait au niveau fac les
services qu utilisent au quotidien si on
est abreuvé comme des cochons avec la
nourriture gratuitement on la mange et
on réfléchit pas et puis ont permis
d'éviter aux saucisses eurofins débiteur
position donc voilà c'est jérémy chardy
dans un instant sur 7 sur cette démarche
active plus qu'à l'information à la
connaissance parce que je pense que
c'est la clé juste apporter une
précision ou 2 tristan quand tu dis il
faut de la crypto oui mais il faut de la
crypto de boutons
c'est ce qu'on appelle entre
l'inscription en anglais par opposition
à la crypto de point à point
à savoir la crypto dans lequel
l'utilisateur génère une clé l'autre
utilisateurs génère une clé par un
échange de clés publiques
on s'assure de pouvoir communiquer par
un canal que l'on estime de confiance
sans avoir besoin de faire confiance à
qui que ce soit d'autre
c'est pas apple qui a la clé google qui
a la clé le certificateur du
certificateur du certificateur du machin
qui a la clé comme quand on utilise
https non non c'est jacky les produits
qui font ça j'ai déjà sur la g kg pour
le mail il ya au tf de records pour le
chat
il ya texte secure est raide faune même
s'ils sont distribués un petit peu
bizarrement quand la thyroïde
on pourrait publier sur le site de
tinker view un lien vers le par exemple
le blog de korben qui relança ou le site
contrôle des données pointent en est
mais c'est passé pas l'objet ici juste
que philosophiquement et
technologiquement c'est quelque chose de
très différent c'est la crypto qui est
aux mains de l'utilisateur par rapport à
juste la crypto aussi rajouter un petit
point quand tu dis auto hébergement je
suis d'accord c'est l'objectif mais
l'auto hébergement c'est l'aboutissement
c'est le degré ultime de la
décentralisation des services et des
communications ce que l'on vit c'est la
décentralisation au lieu en attendant
d'avoir ma freedombox le professeur eben
moglen le grand jeu le plus fort dans
l'âme il ya retiration l'immense
professeur eben moglen a expliqué en
2010 ont déjà sa vision pour une freedom
box qui conduisait à nous nous nous
permettre de décentraliser les services
et les communications
en attendant d'avoir ce gadget que l'on
doit faire avancer qui n'avance pas
aussi vite qu'ils devraient mais qu'on
devrait rendre aussi sexy qu'un iphone
le petit bidule combien dans une prise
et pouic ça y est on a saisi ma chance
chez soi ses mails chez soi on décide de
partager avec qui on veut il ya crypto
qui marche comme cet été en attendant
d'avoir sa 6éme mutualisés à l'échelle
d'une bande de potes à l'échelle d'une
association d'une entreprise ou même
d'une administration publique
c'est déjà vachement mieux que tous
mettent chez google ce qu'on faisait
nous avons non
le l'objectif c'est la décentralisation
et l'auto hébergement c'est
l'aboutissement de sa maintenance que je
voulais ajouter là dessus c'est que
quand on regarde ces technologies qui
libère logiciels libres décentralisation
des services et chiffrement de bout en
bout
ils sont dans le miroir des
caractéristiques des technologies qui
contrôle qui sont logicielles et
matérielles fermé pour qu'on puisse pas
savoir ce qu'ils font service centralisé
pour agréger masse de données les
recouper entre elles profiler profiter
et le faux la faune l'illusion de
sécurité le petit canard tu fermes les
yeux tu fais confiance à google et tout
marche très bien
ces trois caractéristiques des
technologies qui contrôlent repose sur
le même mécanisme qui est de soustraire
à l'utilisateur la capacité de
comprendre si t'as pas le code source du
logiciel site à puce et une boîte noire
soudés entre 18 couche d'époxy dans un
bidule que tu peux toute façon même pas
ouvrir site à l'illusion de sécurité
parce qu'on te t'explique pas comment ça
fonctionne si j'ai cette anecdote
charmante sur quelqu'un qui propose à sa
grand mère mamie que veut regarder tes
mails de mon ordinateur et la grand-mère
qui en toute bonne foi je disais non je
peux pas ils sont sur mon ordinateur qui
se rendait pas compte que se connecter à
google
c'était connecter à gmail c'était se
connecter un ordinateur distant banon ça
paraît dans mon ordinateur donc mes
mails sont dans mon ordinateur
tant qu'on n'a pas conscience de
l'architecturé techno politique des
services et des communications que l'on
utilise alors on est dans l'ignorance et
donc c'est cette ignorance qui est à
dessein construite par les fabricants et
cette alliance entre les fabricants et
les politiques pour nous maintenir dans
l'ignorance pour mieux nous contrôler
alors qu'en face le logiciel libre les
services décentralisés et le chiffrement
de bout en bout sont des technologies
qui sert peuvent paraître un petit peu
difficile à apprendre qui nécessitent
une prise en main un apprentissage une
appropriation peut-être une réunion des
leaders une volonté non point ici c'est
que ça n'est que si on s'approprie ces
technologies qui libère que l'on sera
vraiment libre est ce qu'il ya entre
nous et cette appropriation la plupart
du temps c'est d'un côté le marketing
tous souriants on et vos amis
apple te fait finalement intelligent
google te diront de do not i do not do i
vol etc et de l'autre côté parce que ça
ça avec une partie de la médaille de
l'autre côté une espèce de sentiment
technophobie ambiante ah mais moi tous
ces trucs là à je peux pas parce que je
ne suis pas il est sauté pourquoi pas je
ne suis pas un génie un hacker 1 heure
d'un maroc a expliqué les choses je
cherche à comprendre pourquoi pas
expliqué les choses il date my pointe
c'est que en réalité la seule chose qui
bloque les utilisateurs des technologies
qui libère c'est un apprentissage c'est
une appropriation et c'est en anglais à
cette notion d' empowerment qui n'existe
qu'en l'espagnol d'amérique latine m pod
est la mienne qui est dispo en espagnol
espagnole et qui à ma connaissance
n'existe pas en français autrement
traduit que par capacitation qui est
moche parce que dans empowerment est
dans un mode est la mienne toria cette
notion de pouvoir
ça veut dire ce pas prendre le pouvoir
mais devenir paresseux pour s'approprier
s'approprier le pouvoir est la première
étape pour s'approprier le pouvoir c'est
de comprendre le pouvoir que l'on a mais
maladie pour compléter ce que dit jérémy
moi ce que j'ai remarqué depuis snow
dance et qu' il ya de plus en plus de
solutions
de plus en plus de solutions et de
services qui sortent qui sont orientés
user friendly fac sont simples à
comprendre simple à utiliser
alors c'est pas encore parfait là où il
ya un truc qui pèche c'est que forcément
une solution email même si elle est
super chiffres et même s'il est très
sécurisée elle sera en termes de
fonctionnalités encore moins bien que
gmail par exemple moi bon voila j'ai un
service demain qui passe gmail
j'ai galère quand je vais faire une
recherche parmi mes 418 me wade va c'est
compliqué alors qu'avec j'aimais je
tapais un mot-clé j'ai retrouvé tout de
suite et je trouve ça complètement nul
chez mexx ce que je veux dire par là
c'est qu'en fait ce choix-là peut se
faire ça entraîne en fait une une notion
de perte de confort sur les outils en
tous cas actuellement parce que c'est
pas encore assez développé ce n'est pas
encore assez travaillé parce que les
mecs qui font ça c'est des barbus et ils
ont pas forcément les notions de qualité
qu'on google quand ils font des produits
finis bien en bien emballé avec le
sourire comme 10 et jérémy voilà donc
cette perte de confort il faut là il
faut l'accepter faut la comprendre
c'est comme les gens qui passent
souligne aussi passion et logiciels ils
vont dire ouais mais c'est chiant faux
compilé faux machin c'est compliqué
enfin c'est pas un gré à bhl les fonds
d'écran sont pas jolis la barre est pas
belle enfin peu importe mais c'est la
perte de confort mais d'un autre côté on
gagne en termes et logis pour troller
sur ça je troll avant je te trouve là
pourquoi pas expliqué les chaussures
alors vous savez que sur notre chaîne
youtube on s'intéresse aux problèmes
géopolitiques jeux-stratégie et
financier qu'on a l'opportunité de
parler à des grands financiers des gens
poste ou ayant été en poste
nous nous on voit un petit peu de
parallèle entre la surveillance
d'internet le flicage généralisé
sous des prétextes sous de faux
prétextes et on voit aussi le climat
économique devenir complètement délétère
et la grande peur qu'on a sur notre
chaîne youtube c'est est ce que ce n'est
pas une façon comme une autre
d'anticiper un gros bordel économique
c'est-à-dire de préparer des outils sur
internet pour pouvoir anc liés ou
fichiers ou surveiller des gens n'ayant
pas la même vision économique que le
capitalisme des dégénérés donc nous nous
c'est notre question c'est à dire que
plus la finance est dérégulé plus on
voit la dérégulation d'internet au
mauvais sens du terme à arriver
et quand on vous pose des questions vous
avez très peu de passerelles vous dans
votre milieu avec des financiers et les
gens acteurs sur les places de marché
avec des directeurs de banksy avec ces
choses-là
donc voilà la question que mes auditeurs
me pose c'est est-ce que c'est pas
encore un énième dispositif pour pouvoir
nous visser et nous mettre une camisole
numérique en cas d'effondrement
économique ou en cas de tensions
économiques
c'est ça ton troll pour la literie est
bon et ben pêche un peu de revenir
surtout après je reviens tu reviens
comme tels que je fais comme je le fais
comme chez trucks et eicher de cette
notion perte de confort imagine des gens
qui se disent ils sont bien gentils va
vouloir abolir l'esclavagé et c'est
quand même vachement confortable les
esclaves regarde construisez une maison
ap
elle est construite tu as enfin santé
objet d'en abattre un quand même pour
l'exemple ouidah non tu tues tu délègues
de la même façon le vote des femmes
ça devait être bien confortable avant
pour ceux qui étaient pas des femmes de
pouvoir décider de ce qu'allait être
l'élément à toute l'information nous a
permis le vote des fans pour les taxes
et en tout ce que je veux dire ici c'est
qu'il ya des moments des choix de
société qui sont tellement importants
qu'ils justifient qu'on se passe d'une
partie de nos modes de vie à entendre en
écho de ce que george bush a dit le jour
où il a été élu je crois dire notre mode
de vie n'est pas négociable
donc ça peut être perçu comme une perte
de confort mais quand c'est pour
atteindre des objectifs supérieurs
il sait des choix de société qu'on est
capable de faire qu'on a déjà été dans
l'histoire capables de faire même si le
droit des femmes aujourd'hui n'est pas
dans le monde entier une christine
lagarde a dit que je n'ai pas de
problème avec l'arabie saoudite et
d'autres fatrasie sa carte il est
maintenant pour refermer sur ta question
et le fait d'anticiper les crises que la
surveillance de masse soit un outil de
contrôle social
je pense que c'est évident ce que ce
qu'évoquait tristan tout à l'heure sur
l'autocensure
c'est pas juste l'auto sur la mégère
énumère delà l'heure actuelle la
surveillance de masse on n'est plus à
l'époque de la stasi à l'époque de nos
grands parents où il est tous des
fichiers qui placé des micros chez toi à
la rage des micros qui était la taille
de mon téléphone portable
là on passe à laon pas si aya
surveillance de masse plus la loi de
moore
c'est à dire le doublement des capacités
des composants électroniques tous les
deux ans et on va se retrouver d'ici
trois ans avec une machine ayant des
capacités
digne de super et on attend maintenant
on est déjà dans des capacités dingue
il faut garder à l'esprit que les
documents de snowdon date de 2012 que ça
va bientôt faire trois ans donc ta loi
de moore est elle voilà tu es trois ans
donc c'est déjà pris dans le vent quand
on lisait en 2012 que la nsa été emmerdé
par thor peut-être qu'aujourd'hui le
casque comme ça quand on lisait en 2012
qui n'avaient pas la baguette magique
pour faire péter la crypto si ça se
trouve ils vont péter la crypto etc
donc on est déjà peut-être dépassé par
ce que l'on connaît et ce que l'on
connaît et une échelle qui nous a tous
fait tomber de la chaise même ceux qui
étaient qualifiés de plus paranoïaques
ce qui était le plus prudent avant donc
je suis d'accord avec toi houllebecq les
cheveux dit que c'est presque un c'est
presque un poncif aujourd'hui de dire
que cette surveillance va permettre de
le contrôle social
c'est son objectif premier c'est ta
perception de la shoah elle a été votée
au nom de la lutte contre le terrorisme
on a maintenant démontré par a plus b
qu'elle ne sert à rien contre le
terrorisme et qu'elle est utilisée à des
fins d'espionnage industriel et
d'espionnage politique
ce que l'on sait c'est qu'elle est un
outil de contrôle social et ça de façon
homogène dans l'histoire certes la
choisit c'était pas des enfants comme en
plus il y avait un informateur de la
choisis par 400 habitants ça veut dire
en gros un par pâtés de maisons jamais
une police secrète n'a été aussi
densément informé par sa population et
des micros il y en avait deux dizaines
de types différents et il y avait un
joli arsenal mais oui on est déjà bien
plus loin que la stasi mais lâche l'asie
servait avant tout d'instruments de
contrôle social pour maintenir le régime
en place et de façon consistante dans
l'histoire chaque fois qu'il ya eu
surveillance de masse étaient des
régimes autoritaires qui contrôler leur
population
donc oui c'est évidemment la situation
dans laquelle on est maintenant ce que
je voulais ajouter
et peut-être que c'est ça qui va le
terrain intéressé tes amis financiers où
les gens qui se posent des questions un
peu plus prospective qui raisonne en
termes un petit peu plus lointain que la
prochaine élection par exemple c'est que
dans un modèle de société dans
lesquelles les individus sont mpa old
par l'appropriation de la technologie
par le logiciel libre les services
décentralisés
roman de bout en bout ont bâti un modèle
de sécurité alternatif au modèle de
sécurité centralisé dans lequel l'état
comprend tout entend tout et peut
influer sur tout on a call l'état décide
de quels sites seront accessibles pas
accessible de quel de de quelle
communication sera écoutée ou non
lorsque l'on rend les individus en
quelque sorte responsable d'une partie
de leur communication de la sécurité de
leurs données et de leur communication
ont bâti un modèle de sécurité plus
décentralisée que le modèle de sécurité
centralisé et donc par là on bâtit de la
résilience la résilience et la capacité
à se remettre debout en cas d' attaque
que l'on parle d' attaque terroriste
une data qu'économique ou que l'on parle
de catastrophe naturelle et je pense que
c'est là dessus qu'il faut travailler
c'est sûr développer ensemble social
jacques baudou question tiff une
capacité à bâtir de la résilience des
six lire la critique de ge energy
science informations les riches pas si
on n'y arrive pas c'est laisser les
entreprises américaines et les services
américains parce qu'ils sont plus
puissants parce qu'ils ont un budget de
magnitude
au delà des nôtres prendre le contrôle
de nos économies et nos systèmes
politiques
tristan si on n'y arrive pas tu fais
quoi tu quittes la france ça sera pas
pire ici qu'ailleurs
j'en sais rien mais je prendrai les
armes ouais tu prendras les arbres et
les armes numérique
mais oui des grenades numérique des
lance-roquettes numérique non mais il
s'attend sur les gars coupé pendant les
arrêts acte de résistance c'est vrai ça
va passer j'ai rien tu prendre les armes
toi les armes non non mais faire couler
le sang c'est une
non j'ai nommé par les préfectures
aujourd'hui non demain peut-être est-ce
que je pense qu'il ya des yade est
forcément des tactiques plus efficace
que sa ré écoute par définition
s'immoler devant quelque chose c'est la
lfc chacun sait la tactique d'un
désespéré
même si un jour je suis désespéré je
suis incapable de dire aujourd'hui ce
que je ferais tu l'appelles s'appellera
on ira boire un p'tit coup mais je suis
persuadé qu'on a aujourd'hui la
diversité quasi infini de tactique qui
n'ont pas encore été explorées et qui
repose précisément sur ces technologies
conques ont décrit cette appropriation
repose sur le partage de la connaissance
et ça c'est quelque chose dont on est
tous capables il suffit d'avoir un
cerveau une bouche
peut-être même pas peut-être juste
d'aider main sur un clavier ça suffit il
suffit d'être un être humain pour être
en capacité de partager la connaissance
et je pense que se partagent la
connaissance et la clé alors on force
s'autonomiser et pour bâtir ensemble
cette résilience on passe la parole à
corbehem qui a comme cela on a besoin de
corbeil et d'aujourd'hui le slogan de
korben ceop gris dior bein moi c'est ça
mais oui qu'est ce t'en penses comme ben
moi je suis assez confiant je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi
pour moi c'est ce ce fin de cette
surveillance la publicité le ciblage
séné saynètes où ça de la publicité que
me disait comme disait tristan do de
l'argent de besoin de faire du business
là dessus se sont greffés les
gouvernements parce qu'effectivement
c'est bien pratique d'avoir un facebook
pour aller piocher dans sa finance aussi
les campagnes
ah oui aussi et je pense que avec ce qui
se passe en ce moment avec le le aussi
bon ça va prendre du temps en corse à
apprendre plusieurs années mais le côté
on va dire éducatif la connaissance le
fait comme lingère me disais ça fait 10
ans grand match et a même chose mais ce
genre de choses au bout d'un moment il
va y avoir quand même des boîtes qui
vont se monter les hackers qui vont
réagir des business models qui vont se
monter des choses qui vont payante qui
vont être voilà qui veut qu'ils vont se
financer et qui vont basé leurs business
models comme on le voit maintenant ferme
sur le bio ou sur jeanjean de choses qui
vont bazert business model sur sur la
vie privée / / voilà le chiffrement sur
respect tout ça et peut-être que ça nous
ouvrira des portes de sortie
alors je joue juste une parenthèse et je
vous passe la parole à tous les deux je
tiens à dire que j'ai essayé de faire
venir un représentant du ministère de
l'intérieur monsieur jérémie
rappelle-moi latournerie latournerie
alors vu sa secrétaire qui n'était pas
au fra était pas capable de me donner
autre chose qu'une femme de ménage ou
une assistante et encore ils n'ont pas
voulu se déplacer même un second couteau
ayant la parole du ministère ce n'est
pas possible on a contacté aussi urvoy
pour qu'ils viennent un petit peu nous
parler le député en charge de ces
personnages et la loi sur l'intelligence
tout à fait très occupé très occupé et
on avait convié jean marc manach mais
malade tu t'es dégonflé et on va pas on
va s'en va s'en rappeler mais qu'ils
sont tues tu es bien dégonflé à digérer
que tu dis c'est pas pour pour essayer
mais ce que je pense qu'il faut et
toutes façons nul n'est besoin d'espérer
pour entreprendre
combien de temps ça va nous prendre
sachant que 1 les prochaines lois sont
déjà en train d'être d'être adoptée
quasiment et sachant que une entreprise
comme apple j'ai vu ce chiffre là ces
jours ci est maintenant évalué à 400
milliards de dollars en bourse
donc si apple club des doigts et éternue
un petit milliard de dollars pour faire
du marketing on dirait regarder une
nouvelle iphone 18 et chiffré logiciels
libres tout ce que vous voulez c'est la
solution afin qu'ils sont déjà en train
de le faire google est en train de dire
que oui mais en fait on lutte contre ces
requêtes du gouvernement sur l'esker que
que faire contre une série aya le
greenwashing en matière d'écologie ou
total va investir 0 0 0 0 1 % de ses
revenus
pour blanc planté trois arbres quelque
part en afrique et dire regardez total
c'est l'écologie là je pense qu'on est
en train déjà d'assister une espèce de
prime si washington la chine garde
washing dans lequel tu as un machin qui
sort dit oui c'est chiffré et oui quand
même
exactement exactement ce matin sur
twitter je dis regardez avec apple il ya
un problème dans un des chapitres de mon
livre que j'ai publié en simultané sur
mon blog et là on m'interpelle
oui mais attendez c'est quand même un
regarder ce qu'il faut et on m'envoie
un verre improbable si white paper de
chez apple et je regarde la brouille de
machin il fait j'ai pas combien de
dizaines de pages sont d'accord et à
txema ça a l'air vachement 1
mais je peux rien vérifié de skate d'en
voir si tu peut le vérifier d'une façon
tu peut le vérifier sans ouvrir le
document tu le vérifie en mettant bout à
bout le patriot act et le faiza en
attaque de 2008 qui ensemble font que
apple ne peut pas refuser à l'aîné
salvat cela fait déjà cinq ans que ces
données et ont donné toutes ses clients
j'espère que votre boîte que des petites
boîtes mignonne et où émergent en oui on
affaire d ubuntu fun des firefox trucs
des machins ya gsmk en allemagne nos
amis andy müller maguhn et frank rieger
gens du feu historiquement du ccc qui
font le cryptophone ça fait dix ans
qu'ils bossent dessus
le machin il faut 5 ou 6000 euros parce
que ça fait dix ans qu'ils aient une
équipe de dix bus qui bossent dessus et
c'est pas du logiciel libre donc
commencer aujourd'hui un truc 2 0 ça va
prendre un temps fou
ouais ce que je veux ajouter je suis
d'accord avec toi et je suis d'accord
avec toi en ce sens qui a un boulevard
de marché s'il faut parler en ces termes
là pour la protection de la vie privée
c'est pas que les clients c'est un appel
aux chefs d'entreprise que tu fais là
c'est pas un appel chacun trouvera ce
qu'il veut entendre je parle je ne vais
pas sortir la trompette mais il n'ya pas
que les gens prêts à dépenser 5 ou 6000
euros pour un cryptophone de gsmk qui
ont un intérêt économique ou politique à
protéger leur vie privée
ce que je veux dire c'est que la proche
de dire oh le marché va régler ça on l'a
entendu sur des questions qui avaient
trait à l'environnement la date de l'aïd
raji de la grèce elle avait de la grèce
le système financier etc et on peut dire
que ça marche pas forcément ou en tout
cas on peut investir dans d'autres modes
d'action que ceux qui consiste à dire on
va laisser faire le marché les
entreprises en parallèle des fois que ça
marche pas et ce que je veux dire on a
évoqué sa tout à l'heure mais on n'est
pas le fond du du sujet dont j'ai envie
de revenir là dessus sur les
recommandations en politique parce que
le marché
son truc dans son coin c'est très bien
mais quid des politiques publiques
quid de la mission d'élus dont la
responsabilité est de protéger nos
libertés fondamentales j'ouvre une
parenthèse l'âge mais je fais le 3 nov
j'y tiens qui tient les finances des
partis politiques qui finance les
trésoreries de partis politiques tant je
suis en train de faire de l'asin action
gens en train de faire de la science
fiction
je te parle de gens qui sont à la tête
d'institutions qui sont en train de
perdre leur légitimité qu'ils sont en
train de voir pour les plus lucides
arriver le spectre d'une vague brune
marine ou de machin comme ça au travers
de toute l'europe et on va leur laisser
des outils extraordinaires et qui se
retrouveront à la tête de l'appareil de
surveillance et contrôle social qu'on
est en train de bâtir pour eux
maintenant je te parle de ces
institutions est peut-être plus que des
élus des hauts fonctionnaires et des
gens qui dans les institutions n'ont pas
la liberté de parole mais qui voit très
bien ce qui est en train de se passer et
qui eux ont une certaine marge de
manoeuvre qui eux peuvent appuyer
certaines certaines manettes certaines
bout certains boutons qui peuvent écrire
des notes qui peut faire des suggestions
qui peuvent lui murmurer à l'oreille de
ceux qui parle face caméra qui savent
pas de quoi ils parlent et que quand il
s'agit de politique publique
oui logiciels libres système
décentralisé et chiffrement de bout en
bout
ça devrait être un objectif stratégique
ça devrait être une politique
industrielle la 6è courage de la
sémiologie à tanger j'arrive
j'y arrive ça devrait être une politique
industrielle part et là on peut on peut
s'asseoir avec une bouteille ou deux et
quelques experts et prendre le temps de
détailler ça c'est qu'un embryon liste
ça pourrait être la commande publique
on investit des deniers publics ça
devient des logiciels public donc des
logiciels libres ça pourrait être parler
les programmes de l'éducation supérieure
on va te prendre dans l'éducation
nationale on va t'apprendre
l'informatique oui mais ce sera
l'informatique libre ça pourrait être
par les budgets des militaires et de la
police en matière de sécurité
informatique
un machin comme l'a dit si avec ses 350
acteurs de talent qui développe des
téléphones sécurisés basé sur android
pour en faire tourner 900 exemplaires
pour les ministres et leur entourage
pourquoi moi citoyen français qui
financent l'ansi j'ai pas ce sac droid
dans ma poche
donc il ya plein de biens par lesquels
on pourrait
photo cl incitations fiscales dire une
entreprise si elle prouve que tout ce
qu'elle produit c'est sous gpl une
licence de logiciel libre alors sa tva
clac clac clac parce qu'elle reverse
déjà la seconde interrogé merlieux voilà
pour l'intérêt général
donc ça c'est donc créer le contexte
politique qui fera qui permettra de
faire arriver de telles mesures est
aussi un objectif aujourd'hui mais ce
que je veux ajouter ici c'est que le
logiciel libre par définition c'est un
terrain d'entente commun entre des gens
qui ont des intérêts potentiellement
complètement d'hiver à dire que la msa 1
thales l'ansi est l'équivalent de
l'ansea au togo peuvent au même moment
bosser sur l'audi du même code
identifier des trous de sécurité et
soumettre des patchs
c'est un terrain commun sur lequel on
peut travailler ensemble donc peut-être
que ça sera pas en france
peut-être que ça sera pas en europe
peut-être que ça sera au brésil en inde
ou dans un pays dont on n'est même pas
fichu de même temps de la capitale
peut-être que ça se fera ailleurs est
par définition le logiciel libre permet
que où que ce soit que cela se fasse
c'est l'intérêt général la question
telle vision gaulliste de du mec qui va
s'expatrier pour pouvoir sauver son
territoire c'est ça je suis chez deal et
les analogies historiques c'est un bon
d'accord quand ben qu'est ce t'en penses
au niveau de ses préconisations on
comprend bien que c'est très facile à
mettre en place
ce qu'il faut c'est une volonté il n'y a
pas de volonté politique et
moi j'ai des amis qui bossent outils
bosser un peu plus haut dans les
ministères
et quand ils ont un sujet qu'ils ne
connaissent pas bah ils vont se
renseigner et qu'est-ce qui les
renseignent c'est les industriels et
lobbys les voilà c'est ces gens là dans
leur carnet d adresses
c'est pas les hackers c'est pas les fans
ou de l'eau c'est exceptionnel mais
c'est pas c'est pas voilà c'est pas les
gens qui vivent le truc au quotidien
c'est ce qu'ils font du business avec
donc du coup forcément il oriente ils
donnent leur et voilà il faut marcher le
truc dans leur intérêt donc forcément
utiliser livre enseigné à l'école ou ce
genre de choses c'est raté des instits
ne sera pas une volonté politique
en tout cas je reviens sur jérémy pour
pouvoir faire germer cette volonté est
ce que tu penses qu'il faut avoir un
élément exotique pour les fédérer est ce
que tu penses qu'il faudrait c'est quand
même c'est d'entendre dire ces
préconisations c'est très facile à
mettre en place est bon au niveau de la
sémiologie je me pose la question
pourquoi s'est pas mis en place
le problème c'est que j'ai passé sept
ans à temps plein à courir dans les
couloirs des parlements des ministères
du parlement européen de la commission
européenne etc et que j'en sors avec la
très forte
l'impression qu'il va falloir aller
faire ces choses-là year et en même
temps la conviction qu'il faut pas
abandonner ces terrains là je vais pas
parler en termes aussi cru que la
corruption du processus politique et
pourtant j'ai du mal à trouver d'autres
mots oui une somme d'incompétence de
corruption plus ou moins douce de manque
de courage politique de déconnexion avec
la réalité aussi fait qu'il est
extrêmement difficile de faire avancer
ces choses là donc qu'est-ce qui pourra
impulser ce genre de dynamique
c'est très dur comme question peut-être
peut-être un renouvellement
générationnel de la classe politique
mais je suis pas sûr qu'on ait le temps
d'attendre ça je suis pas sûr que ces
outils de contrôle social vont me
permettre un renouvellement de la classe
politique est un des objectifs de tout
ça c'est peut-être aussi de rester au
pouvoir pour ce qu'ils sont un autre
élément
peut-être c'est un exemple qui vient
d'ailleurs j'ai pas suivi les dernières
étapes d'un test texte qui devait être
adopté par le sait la rrq qu'il
rassemblement tous les pays d'amérique -
les usa et le canada
donc tous les pays d'amérique centrale
latine et des caraïbes qui disent
internet est un bien commun la
surveillance de masse est inacceptable
et si des politiques publiques se
mettent en oeuvre au brésil et ailleurs
commence à générer et un momentum
politique et un momentum économique en
bon suiviste peut-être que les
politiques publiques européennes
s'ils mettront et un autre que
j'aimerais vraiment que l'on évite un
autre paramètre qui pourrait faire
changer les choses c'est une catastrophe
comme on apprend à faire des backups le
jour où mon père un disque dur comme on
apprend le chiffrement le jour où on se
retrouve avec toutes ces données
exposées sur la place publique
j'aimerais pas qu'on en vienne à prendre
le logiciel libre le jour on sera fait
par alizée nono système par des alliés
de l'otan ou par des gens qui auraient
pris le contrôle d'une partie du système
de l'otan et vous sera démontré par a
plus b que notre faiblesse aura été de
dépendre d'entreprises us pour notre no
no no 2 les aspects stratégiques de
notre notre information l'espère triste
on alors moi j'ai un petit espoir dans
le marché et dans les gens qui font du
logiciel libre
comme korben j'essaye de regarder là où
on peut là où les choses peuvent marcher
et puis d'y mettre mon énergie
donc ça commence par l'éducation c'est
pour ça que je fais ce livre en essayant
de le rendre aussi facile d'abord que
possible et puis il ya aussi des gens
qui font du logiciel libre en france et
il n'est pas exclu qu'il y en ait qui
fasse du logiciel libre qui soit
utilisable par tous on a réussi à le
faire à l'époque où j'étais chez mozilla
on l'a fait avec firefox dire qu'on a
fait un logiciel qui est libre mais qui
est facile à utiliser et 450 millions de
personnes l'ont téléchargé et installé
sur leur machine et on a réussi à
remettre le lobe le web d'aplomb
maintenant la problématique j'ai rajeuni
en chaîne il est pas autant aussi droit
que je le souhaite je souhaiterais et
depuis c'est étonnamment concentré
centralisée en silo ce qui finalement le
problème qu'on est en train de décrire
actuellement continue mais il va falloir
trouver de l'énergie pour faire des
logiciels libres au service des
utilisateurs qui répondent à toute la
problématique dont on vient de discuter
mais hélas c'est là où je suis pas
d'accord avec korben c'est que bon
d'accord aujourd'hui on le voit chiffrer
ses mails mais c'est un cauchemar quoi
c'est dur je le fais pas ça fait
quatrième fois que je me remets depuis
2005 art et même 80 99 j'avais déjà
commencé à chiffrer mais c'est vraiment
compliqué et c'est moche et on perd des
fonctionnalités etc
mais il faut pas se résoudre à ça le
système il marchera vraiment où on fera
des logiciels libres et des solutions
libres qui feront meilleur que google et
c'est possible parce que justement c'est
pas google on peut faire ça avec des
acteurs qui ne se qui se méfie de google
mais qui serait d'accord pour partir par
exemple dans une logique d'auto
hébergement ou bien le chiffrement ou le
logiciel combinés ensemble pour être au
service de l'utilisateur et donc il faut
faire mieux
c'est possible mais s'excuser c'est dans
l'état actuel des choses on est obligé
de table du confort et mon espoir c'est
comme celui ci c'est qu'on puisse faire
mieux
en jour on fera mieux les gens vont se
précipiter dessus parce que ça fait
mieux et en plus c'est respectueux de
ton intimité numérique actuellement il
n'y a rien de parfait mais effectivement
je disais fire fois que c'est un bon
exemple de ça c'est pas faillir fois que
cela maintenant on fait quoi
chrome tard et explorer minx ou pas du
tout non mais pas d'une porte pas links
voilà mais ça serait triste fin à dix
ans déjà il ya un projet qu'on n'a pas
mentionné qui en est au stade
embryonnaire et dans lequel ggg espoirs
qui s'appelle cali open et kelly hoppen
c'est laurent chemla qu'initie ça il
serait pas été laurent chemla j aurais
jamais cru
le croire et c'est un projet qui
projette d'unifier une meilleure boxe au
tour de tous les protocoles de
communication pour permettre d'aller le
plus facilement possible vers le
chiffrement là c'est quelque chose si
tes amis et financiers cherchent à
investir dans quelque chose qui fera le
rayonnement français machin machin kahlo
kallio peine les gas et voilà c'est du
bon et la corse quand tu vois quand tu
vois cameron dire qu'il est contre le
chiffre - qui veut interdire le
chauffage avant avance gros morceau la
presse que je suis d'accord avec ce que
disent et tristan et et manu mais il
faut faire mieux en terme de
fonctionnalités tout ce qu'on veut
maintenant il faut aussi faire vachement
mieux en terme de comment on développe
le logiciel libre lui même pas ce que tu
disais firefox saran du logiciel libre
accessible c'est vrai ça rendu chez plus
les termes que tu as utilisé on a on a
réparé le web c'est faux déjà outre le
choix politique de mozilla d'accepter
les drm dans html5 qui a été un coup de
poignard dans le dos du logiciel libre
est la seule justifie clairement ça un
coup de [__] non le seul la seule
justification qu'on a entendu de cette
entreprise qui jusqu'à présent disait
regardez on est les copains l'internet
libre on est le libre on est le libre
c'était oui mais vous comprenez sinon on
va perdre et perdre peut perdre des
parts de marché
ça a été le seul argument pour justifier
qu'on mette un instrument de contrôle au
coeur d'un logiciel comme firefox mais
je sais pas là-dessus même que je veux
trop laid là où je me trouvais sais que
mon firefox
déjà je pense que le web est perdu le
web est perdue parce que la moindre
ajout est qu'on regarde on fait appel à
des à des logiciels du javascript qui va
s'exécuter dans ton navigateur qui vient
de dix ou quinze provenance différents
se traite qu'avec les cdn et les trucs
et des machins c'est mettre son doigt
dans un dans un trou sans accompli qui
on a vu aujourd'hui d'accord ce soir
donc déjà je pense qu'on a perdu le web
comme technologie dans laquelle on
pourrait un jour avoir confiance parce
que un interpréteur javascript dans un
machin comme un navigateur web je sais
pas combien de millions de lignes de
code ya dans firefox mois dans 100
millions c'est énorme c'est un truc
c'est ça doit être dix fois plus de
lignes de code qui en a dans une fusée
dans un dans un et machin les plus
complexes que quelques longs que l'on
maîtrise mais le problème c'est que dans
une fusée
chaque ligne de code qui est écrite et
audités par dix personnes derrière est
audité dix fois et nous on sait écrire
du code c'est facile c'est rigolo un
machin comme comme firefox ya plein de
bénévoles pas payé
machin qui vont contribuer des lignes et
des lignes et des lignes mais la
capacité à tester chaque nouvelle ligne
avec tous et à toutes
reste encore aujourd'hui dans firefox
des lignes de codes qui datent de
netscape
c'est à dire qu'ils ont été foutu là il
ya dix ou quinze ou vingt ans on il nous
faudrait dépenser à à vue menées et je
ne suis pas un financier mais a vu nés
entre une et dix fois plus de ressources
qu'on a investi dans l'écriture du code
dans l'audit du code dans l'audit et
dans les tests non dans le général et ça
c'est un truc qu'on ne connaissait pas
faire qu'on n'a pas théorisé qu'on
laisse pudiquement à d'autres et on l'a
vu cette année il ya des trous de
sécurité majeur dans openssl qui ont
déstabilisé les trois quarts des
serveurs web de la planète glisse dawson
hard lead et peut-être 100 % des
serveurs des entreprises du fortune five
hundred parce que c'était un bon
logiciel qui venait d'une entité qui
avait je crois 4000 $ par mois de budget
le mois on a découvert ça tout le
fortune phison jeunes et 4000 dollars de
budget remplir remplir les pointillés je
tiens juste à dire que chez mozilla le
code il est relue au moins deux fois par
an donc écrit une foire lui une première
fois et ensuite s'il est validé il est
relu par une troisième personne et il ya
forcément des tests qui sont faits
vous êtes vous y êtes remis à combien
pour mettre des drm vous étiez un homme
est ce qu'on peut ce qu'on peut
reprocher il ya une discussion
enfin je veux dire vraiment en amont à
tous et j'ai réglé silence le dr dami
les drm en vomissant lasserre con
pour nous c'est une décision qui nous
aident c'était vraiment ça se cultive et
c'est ce qu'ils ont tiré tant d par
mozilla non non non non c'était pas
c'était pas enfin c'est extrêmement
déplaisant de faire ça parce que enfin
moi je suis farouchement opposé aux drm
maintenant on a eu des débats en interne
et il a fallu trancher et c'était la
moins pire des solutions
entre ça et faire mourir mozilla et
c'était pour nous c'était clair parce
que à partir du moment où tu commences à
dire ah je me refuse à mettre des drm et
puis que netflix qui aux états unis un
succès énorme
et ben si tu peux pas lire netflix dans
firefox en chef d'entreprise entre
l'open son audience et donc et tout sert
plus à rien abîmer n'ont rien à manger
ta [__] il ne s'est pas mal de part de
marché c'est un problème d'un sur le
monde
si tu as trois utilisateurs tu finis
comme opéra et tu change pas le monde
est triste vraiment triste ans et dire
par exemple pour accéder dans un
scénario de science-fiction mais dire
voilà mots d'ici là on arrête parce que
on veut plus pour nous le net c'est plus
un ça c'est un impact non non mais même
même politiquement dire nous on a en
restera le navigateur indépendance et
satar rebelles jamais machin noueront
fans the world était tellement les
changements ne change rien c'est non non
parce que je vois politique c'est un
choix politique mais je vois politique
des termes économiques de part de marché
mais c'est un vrai choix politique et on
est dit là a fait le choix politique qui
était celui des parts de marché celui
d'avoir de l'impact dans le futur tiers
soit tu survis et tu as des parts de
marché et donc tu impact le monde en
dévoilant ses utilisateurs parce que la
façon dont on l'a fait le le bruit les
gens je visais cutter un seul avec
korben raccorde les limites face tu vois
par exemple parler d'eux
dopés nécessaire avec sa faille parce
qu'il ya un bus qui fait n'importe quoi
et parce qu'ils ont 4000 euros de budget
par an ou je sais pas quoi mais le
financement du juste lipse à leurs
problèmes et il y a personne qui finance
sa est ok c'est bien d'être tout blanc
et de s'accrocher à l'est ces valeurs
etc
mais il ya des moments effectivement
comme ce qu'a fait mozilla
avec google ou avec le drm tu es obligé
si tu veux je vais faire des affaires
avec des obligés de de faire un pas de
côté pour continuer à avancer la bonne
direction si non tu crèves
et puis c'est là le sait le chemin qu'il
fut d'accord on refera une émission là
dessus si vous voulez je vais dernière
question une chacun un conseil aux
jeunes générations
c'est classique chaque fois que vous
passez dans l'émission c'est là c'est la
question fatale c'est un conseil aux
jeunes générations une bouteille à la
mer sur internet
on va commencer par corot ben ouais bah
moi si j'ai un truc à dire c'est prenez
pas tout comme enfin toutes les infos
comme elles viennent documenter vous
essayer des trucs trop de temps de
réfléchir
réfléchissez et puis
mettez d'ailleurs pour les mains dans le
cambouis se passe pas si compliqué que
ça quoi enfin faut essayer de se poser
les bonnes questions de creuser quoi
faut creuser
tristan bas ça va un peu dans le même
sens j'irais pas jusqu'a dire qu'il faut
lire mon bouquin qui n'est pas encore
sorti mais c'est ça moi je veux donner
là les billes aux gens pour essayer de
comprendre l'internet et commencer à
agir ne faut pas tomber dans la
résignation
c'est ça la difficulté aujourd'hui agir
dans toute la sphère ayant ce et ceux
des brouillards il ya cette impression
d'impuissance les entreprises vous
disent qu'avec apple c'est magique
et donc on est passif ou bien sinon
c'est l'horreur non il y as possibilité
de faire des choses il faut creuser
l'informatique c'est passionnant enfin
je pense qu'on a aimé tous convaincus au
tour cette table et donc il faut prendre
son destin en main commencé à bidouiller
regarder ce qu'on peut faire avec des
logiciels libres et c'est assez excitant
et on se sent un parole on sent qu'on
reprend le pouvoir et c'est fun et en
plus ça nous sert pour l'avenir j invite
mais moi j'ai l'impression de dire un
petit peu la même chose à savoir
questionner tout question se demander
des réponses ou se questionner
questionné par exemple se questionner
soi même quand on a chaque fois on fait
un choix
le remettre en question posez la
question à d autres prendre notre avis
quand on lit quelque chose le
questionner c'est-à-dire croisé ses
sources et aussi questionné l'autorité
et ne jamais rien prendre pour argent
comptant
toujours vérifier les choses avant se
faire sa propre opinion
c'est aaron schwartz qui disait lisez
posez vous les questions et qu'une
grande partie de ce que l'on appelle
l'intelligence est en fait de la
curiosité et cette curiosité je pense
que c'est ce qu'il ya au coeur de la
démarche à coeur de cette cet
enthousiasme vis-à-vis de la technologie
qui pousse à toujours vouloir contrôler
la technologie plutôt qu'être contrôlé
par l je pense que c'est 1 1
un des enjeux de société des plus
importants pour le futur de nos de nos
de notre humanité et que ce qui a été
corrompu là c'est notre rapport à la
technologie
on s'est fait chiper on s'est fait voler
on s'est fait voler le contrôle de nos
deux
machine qu'il s'agit de le reprendre
mais pour le reprendre il faut se poser
la question de ce rapport à la
technologie se poser la question de
comment fonctionne la technologie et se
poser la question de comment à titre
individuel et à titre collectif on va on
va changer tout ça messieurs merci merci